hey guys Pete here gonna follow up on my
last Game of Thrones video about bran
and his purpose that was based off the
history and lore clip the children of
the forest versus the first men today
I'm gonna talk about the tourney at
Harrenhal clip which didn't add as much
but did leave out one major bit that can
provide some height to the future
seasons of Game of Thrones this video is
pretty light on spoilers so I think
everyone can watch unless you're just
not up with the story itself now let's
get into it the history and lore series
includes a retelling of the tourney at
Harrenhal which is narrated by Ellie
Kendrick who plays mirror read on the
show I won't go through the whole
history of the tourney I have an older
video that explains all that led up to
the event and you can actually watch the
whole history and lore clip on Watchers
on the walls YouTube channel since they
had exclusive rights to release the
video a few days ago I'll put links in
the description so you can learn more
about the tourney that way the main
point is that this is one of the biggest
events if not the biggest events that
led to everything that's going on in
Game of Thrones right now and the
children versus the first men clip they
added some interesting bits which I
thought were big clues to how his story
would go but what's more interesting
about this clip is what they've left out
mirror tells the story of her father
Howland Reed attending the largest Tony
Westeros had ever seen in the book she
refers to him as a chronic man rather
than using her father's name but it's
clearly implied so that's no big shocker
she tells how he's beaten up by three
Squires who attack him basically bully
him because he's smaller and they don't
feel like he belongs there we also get
some nice shots of the tourney area and
Harrenhal itself and we see the went
sigil with its nine black bats hanging
in the background so anyways Halla reed
is attacked by three Squires and then
he's rescued by Lyanna stark she comes
out with the turning sword and chases
the Squires away defending her father's
man as the reeds are sworn to house
stark after the incident she takes him
back to her tent to care for his wounds
and he meets her three brothers there
Brandon the
1 Ned the quiet one and benjin the
youngest one the starts tell him there's
going to be a feast that night to
celebrate the opening of the tournament
and he should be there with them Liana
says he's of high birth and he has a
right to sit there on the bench with all
the other families and he mentions that
she's hard to say no to at the feast we
see everything happened as it does in
the books we see Rhaegar playing his
song and Liana crying because it's so
beautiful and we see that Robert the
future king wins a drinking contest let
me get a shot of a shot of Dane and that
whole story which is kind of exciting
because the show's never really
mentioned her and it goes on to say that
she danced with several notable people
including Sir Barristan Selmy and that
Brandon the wild wolf asked her to dance
with Ned who was too shy to do it
himself
then the Mad King shows up and we know
that this happens because Varys warned
him that his son Rhaegar was holding the
tournament or was behind the tournament
to try to get the power together to
possibly figure out getting rid of him
because of his madness we see him knight
Sir Jaime to the Kingsguard and then we
see that Howland Reed and Liana
see the three Squires that attacked him
earlier in that day benjin offers to
give Palin you know some armor and a
horse so that he can take them on but he
realizes in the back of his mind that he
has no chance against them so we see him
go and he spends the night with in Med's
tent but before he goes he prays to the
old gods which this clip doesn't really
talk about it but he had just spent
quite a bit of time on the Isle of faces
before this tour knee went down so he
looks in that direction and he prays to
the old gods the next day the Knights
who Squires had beat up Howland Reed
advance in the tourney and then towards
the end of the day a mystery Knight
appears the night has ill-fitting armor
and is small in stature and the only
thing that we really know for sure is
that they carried a shield that was
painted with the white weirwood that had
a laughing expression and the
the red leaves all around it says the
old gods brought strength to their arm
and they fell all three of the nights
when those nights came to ransom their
horses and armor the knight of the
Laughing tree said with a booming voice
that they needed to teach their Squires
honor and that would be ransom enough
now some fans have taken this to be
confirmation that the knight of the
Laughing tree is actually Liana Point I
guess they're saying is that whenever
she says teach your Squires honor
there's an echo added to the recording
which we don't hear in other parts I
think it's pretty flimsy although I
don't really think there's much in the
way of mystery about her you know her
being the knight of the Laughing tree I
know there's holes in the theory and so
don't go ahead and make a bunch of
comments explaining why you think it
doesn't add up I'm well aware of those I
just don't think there's another good
explanation for who it is
so yeah read it sort of had a big
contingency that was saying that this
was confirmation
without a doubt that Liana is the knight
of the Laughing tree but I think the
evidence is flimsy there so the common
folk and everyone really enjoyed this
but the king being crazy got paranoid
about who this actual mystery Knight was
so here there's a slight change in the
way it's described and I think this is
what is kind of interesting about the
whole video clip in the books
Robert brags that he'll beat the night
the next day more or less in the video
clip it describes it as Mad King Aerys
telling him or asking him to do that
same thing but what's interesting is is
that they also directly King Aerys asked
his son Rhaegar to go out and find out
who the mystery knight is and this leads
to all the speculation about him meeting
Liana and then you know what happens
later whenever he names her the queen of
love and beauty instead of mentioning
that Rhaegar went off to look for the
knight of the Laughing tree it just ends
with Mirror recounting asking her father
about what else happened it mentions
Rhaegar here and how he won the
tournament I mean they didn't change
anything like that but he doesn't want
to talk about what happened and he
doesn't he makes clear or
rather I should say mirror makes clear
that he never spoke about this incident
again so what I think is interesting
here is that they purposely omitted the
section where Rhaegar is the one who's
supposed to go out and look for the
identity and that he was directly sent
by his father the king
I think this leads to us getting an idea
that in the same way that the other clip
kind of steered us in how we should be
thinking about bran I think that they'll
I mean this is obviously a big part of
the entire story that they took out and
it's not like they don't mention Rhaegar
like he doesn't exist they just take out
this one specific part which leads me to
believe that they're saving that for a
flashback either in the next season or
season eight I mean you guys tell me
what you think but why else did they
take this out of here
we had one early trailer that was quite
a while ago now that came out right
after season six and there's another
thing I remember about that where we did
see the sigil of the bat and some people
at that time we're talking about that
this stuff that they were putting
together was had to be have had to have
something to do with Harrenhal since
house went doesn't come up in a lot of
other things but if we combine that with
this I think it pretty much gives us a
good clue that we will see more through
brand about Rhaegar and Lyanna and
obviously how their relationship before
the tower of joy played out that's
pretty exciting I mean we've been
theorizing about it forever and I think
this would be really cool and I think
it's a very likely possibility at this
point but let me know what you guys
think do you think they left it out on
purpose I mean they had to write do you
think that means we're gonna see this
like the meeting between them when he
goes to find out who the knight is or do
you think it's just wishful thinking on
my part let me know what you think in
the comments about this and everything
else and what your favorite history and
lore clips been so far don't forget I'm
having a giveaway and all you have to do
is subscribe and leave a comment on this
or any other video where I mentioned
this specific giveaway to enter once I
reach 28 thousand subscribers I'll pick
one comment from
the videos and I'll send that person a
copy of the 20th anniversary edition of
a game of throne thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon